[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
caroline
chapter 13
caroline's parents never seem to
remember anything
about their time in the snow globe at
least they never said anything about it
and caroline never mentioned it to them
sometimes she wondered whether they had
ever noticed that they had
lost two days in the real world
and came to the eventual conclusion that
they had not
then again there are some people who
keep track of every day and every hour
and there are people who don't and
caroline's parents
were solidly in the second camp
caroline had placed the marbles beneath
her pillow before she went to sleep that
first night home
in her own room once more she went back
to bed after she saw the other mother's
hand
although there was not much time left
for sleeping and she rested her head
back
on that pillow something scrunched
gently as she did
she sat up and lifted the pillow the
fragments of the glass marbles that she
saw looked
like the remains of eggshells one finds
beneath trees
in springtime like empty broken robin's
eggs
or even more delicate ren's eggs
perhaps whatever had been inside the
glass spheres had gone
caroline thought of the three children
waving goodbye to her
in the moonlight waving before they
crossed that silver stream
she gathered up the eggshell thin
fragments with care
and placed them in a small blue box
which had once held a bracelet
that her grandmother had given her when
she was a little girl
the bracelet was long lost but the box
remained
miss [ __ ] and miss forcible came back
from visiting miss pink's niece
and caroline went down to their flat for
tea
it was a monday on wednesday caroline
would go back to school
a whole new school year would begin
miss forcible insisted on reading
coraline's tea leaves
well looks like everything's mostly ship
shape and bristol fashion lovey
said miss forcible sorry
said caroline everything is coming up
roses
said miss forcible well almost
everything i'm not sure what
that is she pointed to a clump of tea
leaves sticking to the side of the cup
miss [ __ ] tutted and reached for the
cup honestly miriam
give it over here let me see she blinked
through her thick spectacles
oh dear no i have no idea what that
signifies it looks almost like a hand
caroline looked the clump of leaves did
look a little like a hand
reaching for something hamish the scotty
dog
was hiding under miss forcible's chair
and he wouldn't come out
i think he was in some sort of a fight
said miss [ __ ]
he has a deep gash in his side poor dear
we'll take him to the vet later this
afternoon
i wish i knew what could have done it
something carl i knew would have to be
done
that final week of the holidays the
weather was magnificent
as if the summer itself were trying to
make up for the miserable weather they'd
been having
by giving them some bright and glorious
days before it ended
the crazy old man upstairs called down
to caroline
when he saw her coming out of miss pink
and miss forcible's flat
hey hi you caroline
he shouted over the railing it's
coraline
she said how are the mice something
has frightened them said the old man
scratching his moustache
i think maybe there is a weasel in the
house
something is about i heard it in the
night in my country
we would have put down a trap for it
maybe put down a little meat or a
hamburger
and when the creature comes to feast
then bam
it would be caught and never bother us
more
the mice are so scared they will not
even pick up their little musical
instruments
i don't think it wants meat said
caroline
she put her hand up and touched the
black key that hung
about her neck and she went inside
she bathed herself and kept the key
around her neck the whole time she was
in the bath
she never took it off anymore
something scratched at her bedroom
window after she went to bed
caroline was almost asleep but she
slipped out of her bed and pulled open
the curtains
a white hand with crimson fingernails
leapt from the window ledge onto a
drainpipe and was immediately out of
sight
there were deep gouges in the glass on
the other side of the window
caroline slept uneasily that night
waking from time to time to plot and
plan and ponder then falling back into
sleep never quite certain where her
pondering
ended and the dream began one ear always
open for the sound of something
scratching at her window pane
or at her bedroom door
in the morning caroline said to her
mother
i'm gonna have a picnic with my dolls
today
can i borrow a sheet an old one one you
don't need any longer
as a tablecloth i don't think we have
one of those
said her mother she opened the kitchen
drawer that held the napkins and the
tablecloths
and she prodded about in it hold on will
this do
it was a folded up disposable paper
table cloth
covered with red flowers left over from
some picnic they've been on several
years before
that's perfect said coraline
i didn't think you played with your
dolls anymore
said mrs jones i don't
admitted coraline their protective
coloration
well i'll be back in time for lunch said
her mother have a good time
caroline filled a cardboard box with
dolls and with several plastic dolls
teacups
she filled a jug with water then she
went outside
she walked down to the road just as if
she were going to the shops
before she reached the supermarket she
cut across the fence
into some wasteland and along an old
drive
and crawled under a hedge she had to go
under the hedge in two journeys
in order not to spill the water from the
jug
it was a long roundabout looping journey
but at the end of it caroline was
satisfied
that she had not been followed she came
out behind the dilapidated old tennis
court
she crossed over it to the meadow where
the long grass swayed
she found the planks on the edge of the
meadow they were astonishingly heavy
almost too heavy for a girl to lift even
using all her strength
but she managed she didn't have any
choice
she pulled the planks out of the way one
by one grunting and sweating with the
effort
revealing a deep round brick-lined hole
in the ground
it smelled of damp and the dark
the bricks were greenish and slippery
she spread out the tablecloth and laid
it carefully
over the top of the well she put a
plastic doll's cup
every foot or so at the edge of the well
and she weighed each cup down
with water from the jug
she put a doll in the grass beside each
cup making it look as much like a doll's
tea party
as she could then she retraced her steps
back under the hedge along the dusty
yellow drive
around the back of the shops back to her
house
she reached up and took the key from
around her neck
she dangled it from the string as if the
key were just something she liked to
play with
then she knocked on the door of miss
pink and miss forcible's flat
miss pink open the door hello dear
she said i don't want to come in said
caroline
i just wanted to find out how hamish was
doing
miss spinks sighed the vet says that
hamish
is a brave little soldier she said
luckily the cut doesn't seem to be
infected we cannot imagine
what could have done it the vet says
some animal he thinks but has
no idea what mr bobo
says he thinks it might have been a
weasel
mr bobo the man in the top flat
mr bobo fine old circus family i believe
romanian or slovenian or livonian or one
of those countries
bless me i can never remember them
anymore
it had never occurred to caroline that
the crazy old man upstairs actually had
a name
she realized if she'd known his name
was mr bobo she would have said it every
chance she got
how often do you get to say a name like
mr bobo allowed
oh said caroline to miss [ __ ]
mr bobo right
well she said a little louder
i'm going to go and play with my dolls
now
over by the old tennis court round the
back
nice dear said miss pink then she added
confidentially
make sure you keep an eye out for the
old well mr lovett who was here before
your time said that he thought it might
go down for half a mile or
caroline hoped that the hand had not
heard this last
and she changed the subject this key
said coraline loudly
oh it's just some old key from our house
it's part of my game
that's why i'm carrying it around with
me on this piece of string
well goodbye now
what an extraordinary child said miss
[ __ ] to herself
as she closed the door
caroline ambled across the meadow toward
the old tennis court
dangling and swinging the black key on
its piece of string as she walked
several times she thought she saw
something the color of bone
in the undergrowth it was keeping pace
with her
about 30 feet away she tried to whistle
but nothing happened
so she sang out loud instead a song her
father had made up for her when she was
a little baby and which had
always made her laugh it went
oh my twitchy witchy girl
i think you are so nice i give you bowls
of porridge and i give you bowls of ice
cream i give you lots of kisses and i
give you lots of hugs but i never give
you sandwiches with bugs
in that was what she sang as she
sauntered through the woods
and her voice hardly trembled at all
the doll's tea party was where she had
left it
she was relieved that it was not a windy
day for everything was still
in its place every water-filled plastic
cup weighed
down the paper tablecloth as it was
meant to
she breathed a sigh of relief now was
the hardest part
hello dolls she said brightly it's tea
time
she walked close to the paper tablecloth
i brought the lucky key she told the
dolls to make sure we have a good
picnic and then as carefully as she
could
she leaned over and gently placed the
key
on the tablecloth she was still holding
onto the string she held her breath
hoping that the cups of water at the
edges of the well would weigh the cloth
down
letting it take the weight of the key
without collapsing into the well
the key sat in the middle of the paper
picnic cloth
caroline let go of the string and took a
step back
now it was all up to the hand
she turned to her dolls who would like a
piece of cherry cake
she asked jemima pinky primrose
and she served each doll a slice of
invisible cake
on an invisible plate chattering happily
as she did so from the corner of her eye
she saw something bone
white scamper from one tree trunk to
another closer and closer she forced
herself
not to look at it jemima
said caroline what a bad girl you are
you've dropped
your cake now i'll have to go over and
get you a whole new slice
and she walked around the tea party
until she was on the other side of it
to the hand she pretended to clean up
spilled cake
and to get jemima another piece
and then in a skittering chittering rush
it came
the hand running high on its fingertips
scrabbled through the tall glass
and then in a skittering chittering rush
it came the hand running high on its
fingertips
scrabbled through the tall grass and up
onto a tree stump
it stood there for a moment like a crab
tasting the air
and then it made one triumphant nail
clacking leap
onto the center of the paper tablecloth
time slowed for caroline the white
fingers closed around the black
key and then the weight and the momentum
of the hand sent the plastic doll's cups
flying and the paper tablecloth the key
and the other mother's right hand went
tumbling down
into the darkness of the well
coraline counted slowly under her breath
she got up to 40 before she heard a
muffled splash
coming from a long way below
someone had once told her that if you
look up at the sky from the bottom of a
mine shaft even in the brightest
daylight
you see a night sky and stars
caroline wondered if the hand could see
stars from where it was
she hauled the heavy planks back onto
the well
covering it as carefully as she could
she didn't want anything to fall in
she didn't want anything ever to get out
then she put her dolls on the cups back
in the cardboard box she'd carried them
out in
something caught her eye while she was
doing this and she straightened up in
time to see the black
cat stalking towards her its tail
held high and curling at the tip like a
question mark
it was the first time she'd seen the cat
in several days
since they'd returned together from the
other mother's place
the cat walked over to her and jumped up
onto the planks that covered the well
then
slowly it winked one eye at her
it sprang down into the long grass in
front of her
and rolled over onto its back wiggling
about
ecstatically caroline scratched and
tickled the soft fur on its belly
and the cat purred contentedly
when it had had enough it rolled over
onto its front once more
and walked back toward the tennis court
like a tiny patch of midnight
in the midday sun
caroline went back to the house mr bobo
was waiting for her in the driveway
he clapped her on the shoulder the mice
tell me that all
is good he said they say that you are
our savior
caroline it's caroline mr bobo
said caroline not caroline
coraline coraline
said mr bobo repeating her name to
himself with wonderment
and respect very good
coraline the mice say that i must tell
you
that as soon as they are ready to
perform in public you will come up
and watch them as the first audience of
all they will play
temptati and toodloodle and they will
dance and do a thousand tricks
that is what is they say
i would like that very much said
caroline
when they're ready she knocked at miss
pink and miss forcible's door
miss pink let her in and caroline went
into their parlor
she put a box of dolls down on the floor
then she put her hand into her pocket
and pulled out the stone
with the hole in it here you go
she said i don't need it anymore i'm
very grateful
i think it may have saved my life and
saved some other people's death
she gave them both tight hugs although
her arms
barely stretched around miss pink and
miss forcible smelled like the raw
garlic she had been cutting
then caroline picked up her box of dolls
and went out
what an extraordinary child said miss
[ __ ]
no one had hugged her like that since
she had retired from the theater
that night caroline lay in bed all
bathed
teeth cleaned with her eyes open
staring up at the ceiling it was warm
enough that
now that the hand was gone she had
opened
her bedroom window wide she'd insisted
to her father
that the curtains not be entirely closed
her new school clothes were laid out
carefully on her chair
for her to put on when she woke
normally on the night before the first
day of term
coraline was apprehensive and nervous
but she realized there was nothing left
about school
that could scare her anymore
she fancied she could hear sweet music
on the night air
the kind of music that can only be
played
on the tiniest silver trombones and
trumpets and bassoons
on piccolos and tubers so delicate and
small that their keys
could only be pressed by the tiny pink
fingers
of white mice caroline imagined
that she was back again in her dream
with the two girls and the boy
under the oak tree in the meadow
and she smiled
as the first stars came out
caroline finally allowed herself to
drift into sleep
while the gentle upstairs music of the
mouse
circus spilled out onto the warm
evening air telling the world
that the summer was almost done
[Music]
you